welcome to this video playing front
knock down from dr. from Argentina
okay the ROI hmm okay but can I do
something else but I really don't want
to I'm glad to at least have one opening
that I know a little bit so let's play
the the usual stuff now in cubic a4 hmm
that really is a difference here yeah
it's right
hmm interesting yeah I don't like to
play before but that's really the way it
is played I believe okay let's try to
avoid that I don't like it to play
before
95 was also an interesting way to play
okay now you can still play 95 em
yeah I wonder Bishop takes Knight before
c4 there how bad is that really I don't
know not totally sure about it
because maybe I can do it maybe I can
play that and now 97 to see fire but
this night on before it I don't know it
looks it can can be a little bit
unstable as a test no retreat square oh
wait I have 93 though but this this
first should be good yeah yeah that's
okay he really has no square for the
bishop now oops
I can take B 395 now why not let's let's
just grab everything and I'll try to
activate the bishop
you 494 it's not a very stable piece
I mean this having rook e8 I don't know
yeah okay it's a pawn
maybe d5 is a move now
d5 intending c5 and deform yeah okay
let's be quick about it not get into
time pressure at least not into crazy
time pressure okay well here I can I can
do a simple thing directly or not okay
let's let's take it directly and then go
to b3
I might have rook b3 he might have
worked if one with the intention to play
queenie form but I have worked d8 okay
rook t1 Group D 824 I can take you for
okay
okay what I wanted to make sure is that
I get to block eight this pawn on b2 we
are not that he can push before quickly
that makes things a lot easier for black
he I guess Here I am - to make sure the
rook is not invading
there is some counterplay here right
Quinn here check and rook e8 that's not
so good that allowed something like that
hmm okay
and don't really see any big account and
many of the alternative here though I
can't go here a Queenie seven I've rook
b7 and he really has no good square for
the Queen
okay that's important no that's that's
okay that's probably okay now we need
seven rugby 7s rather embarrassing for
white okay if he has to go Queen d6 I
just take it player up to seven and wind
up on the second pawn for a very good
route end game right reason yeah I mean
very good as a little bit of a mind but
evaluation I'm just winning them yeah
okay that was happening quickly yeah he
was simply overlooking this little
little tactic here I think maybe I'm
really okay yeah I wasn't sure because
of this somewhat over yet night position
but the way it went I really was in good
shape but yeah he just he just blundered
this pawn that's interesting the
computer has an interesting move here to
suggest which looks kinda crazy but on a
second look at it is quite good yes c5
is quite good stopping the b-pawn and I
get to play f5 Bishop f/64 and he I
control d4 very very safely oh that's a
good idea okay this is this isn't isn't
bad as well keeps keeps a big edge
yeah I hope I played this all right
it seems yeah Quinn v8 was necessary and
now he really does not have a good move
maybe the relatively best is to take and
play a rook a six but he will probably
lose him
this this and d43 I cannot believe that
this should be winning for black okay
good game I think thanks for watching